[Music]
in tahanu her fourth earth sea novel
ursula k le guin is going to provide us
with some new and very important
information about the relationship
between dragons and human beings which
other than in the previous novel the
farthest shore towards the end of the
novel has been rather antagonistic
across the board dragons are these
massive creatures who you know you can't
look into their eyes they speak the true
language they're incredibly dangerous to
deal with there are very few dragon
lords because there are not just very
few people the dragons will speak with
but very few who survive the encounters
in this we find out that there was
actually a deeper connection between
human beings and dragons and in both
cases
it is
relying on a story that is a story
within a story within a story so ogien
the mage
is the person who is relating the story
originally a story that he learns from
somebody else who happens to be a dragon
and then he tells tenor
and then tenor is going to tell this
early on in the novel to therau her her
adopted child and then later on to
ged her by that time
lover really husband and adoptive father
of pharaoh as well and let's pick up
with the the second one in both cases
the story comes up in a kind of offhand
way gad and theroux are talking about or
get antenna are talking about how thero
ought to be
educated and tenor tells him well you
know i only told her one
word of the old or the true language
and god says well why did you do that
and he said and she says well i thought
it was because i'd never truly spoken
that language never used it in majorie i
thought perhaps you should learn it from
a true speaker of it and get says well
no human being is actually a true
speaker of that the dragons speak it as
their native tongue and then she asked
do they learn it and ged says i don't
know
what do we know about them what would
they teach as we do mother to child
elder to younger or are they like the
animals teaching some things but born
knowing most of what they know even that
we don't know but my guess would be the
dragon and the speech of the dragon are
one
one being
and then
tener says they don't speak any other
language and and he says yeah they don't
learn they they simply are and they
start to talk about pharaoh
singing and whether she sings at all and
what the song she's singing in and tenar
says
that story did oja never tell you about
the woman of kameh
and gad says no tell me and she told him
the tale as she spun and the pur and
hush of the wheel went along with the
words of the story
and so that is
one telling of it later on get is now
fully informed what was the earlier
telling
she starts out by
saying
one of the things wizards can do this is
talking to pharaoh is to turn into
something else take another form
and then she says the story i'm going to
tell you is about something like shape
changing but ogen said it was beyond all
shape changing
because it was about being two beings
two beings at once and in the same form
and he said this is beyond
the power
of wizards but he met with it in a
little village around the northwest
coast of gantt a place called kameh
there's an old woman there an old
fisherman fisher woman not a witch not
learned but she made songs and that's
how ogian came to hear of her
she
apparently has come up with this song
that he hears farther west and west
beyond the land my people are dancing on
the other wind and ogin says where did
this song come from and they said well
the woman of khame you know it's her
song go check her out
and here's where it gets really
interesting so ojin goes to
kameh and he finds her
little place her house down by the
harbor he knocks on the door with his
mages staff she comes and opens the door
and then here's where where tenar is
teaching there she says now you know we
remember when we talked about names how
children have child names and everyone
has a use name and maybe a nickname too
different people may call you
differently you're my pharaoh but you'll
have a heartache use name when you get
older also when you come into your
womanhood you will if all be rightly
done be given your true name it will be
given you by one of true power a wizard
or a mage because that's their power
their art naming and that's the name
you'll never tell another person because
yourself is in your true name it's your
strength your power but to another it is
risk and burden only to be given an
utmost need and trust but a great mage
knowing all names may know it without
you telling him so ojin who is a great
mage stood at the door of the little
house there by the sea wall and the old
woman opened the door then ogien stepped
back held up his oak staff put out his
hand too like this as if trying to
protect himself from the heat of the
fire and in his amazement and fear he
said her true name aloud
dragon now notice this is quite
interesting
dragon is a class name but in the case
of this woman it is also her
true name so she's a dragon called
dragon right so that's that's you know
perhaps a funny twist
and in that first moment he told me it
was no woman he saw it all in the
doorway but a blaze and glory of fire a
glitter of gold scales and talons and
the great eyes of a dragon
then that was gone and he saw no dragon
but an old woman standing there in the
doorway a bit stooped a tall old
fisherman with big hands
she looked at him as she did as he did
at her and she said come in lord ogin so
he went in
she serves him fish soup and they ate
and they talked by her fire and he's
wondering well what what is he or what
is she is she a shape changer but is she
a
woman who can change herself into a
dragon or a dragon who could change
herself into a woman so he asks her at
last the question
are you woman or are you dragon and she
didn't say
but she said i'll sing you a story that
i know and here
we get the vital bit of information
the new lore
about dragons and human beings that is
going to prove
very important in this work and in the
others as well
so this is the story
when sugoi raised the islands of the
world from the sea in the beginning of
time the dragons were the firstborn of
the land and the wind blowing over the
land so the song of the creation tells
but her song told also that in the
beginning
dragon and human were one
they were all one people one race winged
and speaking the true language they were
beautiful and strong and wise and free
so human beings and dragons go back to a
common ancestor from the very beginning
of earthsea when segoy raises the
islands from the the water itself and
creates
living beings living rational
beings so
what happens in over in time nothing can
be without becoming so the dra among the
dragon people some became more and more
in love with flight and wildness and
would have less and less to do with
works of making or with study and
learning or with houses and cities they
only wanted to fly farther and farther
hunting and eating their kill ignorant
and uncaring seeking more freedom and
more
others of the dragon people came to care
little for flight but gathered up
treasure wealth things made things
learned they built houses strongholds to
keep their treasures in so they could
pass all they gained to their children
ever seeking more increase and more and
they came to fear the wild ones who
might come flying and destroy all their
deer horde burn it up in a blast of fire
out of mere carelessness and ferocity
the wild ones feared nothing they
learned nothing because they were
ignorant and fearless they could not
save themselves when the flightless ones
trapped them as animals and killed them
but other wild ones would come flying
and set the beautiful houses of fire and
destroy and kill those who were
strongest or wild or wise were those who
killed each other first so we have
conflict now between the peoples the
dragons
and the human beings
and those who are the strongest are
opposing each other fighting each other
and ultimately dying
so he she goes on and says those who are
most afraid they hid from the fighting
when there was no more hiding they ran
from it they used their skills of making
and made boats and sailed east away from
the western isles where the great winged
ones made war among the ruined towers
like at celador for example so those who
had been both dragon and human changed
becoming two peoples the dragons
always fewer and wilder scattered by
their endless mindless greed and anger
in the far islands of the western reach
and the human folks always more numerous
in their rich towns and cities filling
up the inner isles and all the south and
east
and then
there's a little wrinkle to it among
them there were some who saved the
learning of the dragons
the true language of the making these
are now the wizards so some humans
can speak this original language at
least parts of it and that is what
allows them their craft their wizardry
in the case of the mages they're majory
as well
so now we've got two very different
groups don't we
there's a fourth
wrinkle to this
also the song said there are among us
those who who they
who know they once were dragons and
among the dragons there are some who
know their kinship with us
and these say that when the one people
were becoming two some of them
still both human and dragon still winged
went not east
but west
on over the open sea to they ca until
they came to the other side of the world
there they live in peace great winged
beings both wild and wise with human
mind and dragon heart and so she's
saying
farther west and west beyond the land my
people are dancing on the other wing
and then ogien says when i first saw you
i saw your true being this woman who
sits across from the hearth for me is no
more than the dress she wears she shook
her head and laughed and all she would
say is if only it were that
simple and ogin himself speculates about
this
uh ever since that day i've wondered if
anyone man or dragon has been farther
west than west and who we are and where
our wholeness
lies ogian instead of taking this as
well this is a cool origin story he's
thinking about
how can we
reunite be reintegrated together there
are these people further west great wing
beings with both wild and wise
with you know
human mind dragon heart and then there
are
this you know connection between the
dragons who still exist
some of whom still remember the the
origins the human beings some of whom
are still interested in connecting with
the dragons many of whom are opposed to
each other
and there's also
this question well what about
human beings
that
seem like they could be
dragons
and we do also find out that every once
in a while a very
unusual thing happens a human being is
born
among human beings
who is actually a dragon a reversion
back to
the original stock you might say
in the case of this this story
so
we now know
that dragons are not just some evil
mythical beast that comes in and must be
opposed and destroyed
but rather that dragons and human beings
bear a lineage that goes back to the
very creation and
might in some respects be
reintegrated within the world of earth
sea
you